[Musica]
come interpretiamo il benessere e
successo in un territorio turistico
immaginiamo di sfogliare un manuale di
marketing applicato ai servizi turistici
specifico volume sul destination
management probabilmente troveremo
alcune risposte che oggi potremmo
definire incomplete quale il
tracciamento di arrivi e presenze
turistiche a partire dagli ultimi anni
anche il monitoraggio in forma aggregata
attraverso l'utilizzo dell'intelligenza
artificiale dei big data della
reputazione digitale di un territorio
questi sono dati sicuramente importanti
che tantissime destinazioni usano ancora
ma da soli non bastano più sono in grado
di restituirci solo delle piccole
porzioni del complesso fenomeno
turistico in quanto metri che immaginate
costruite applicando le teorie più
comuni alle industrie che sviluppano
prodotti replicabili non sempre possiamo
ritenerle soddisfacenti ed esaustive
soprattutto se ci interessa adottare uno
sguardo d'insieme della destinazione il
turismo non è solo un industria e
soprattutto un fenomeno sociale che
ingloba interconnette almeno tre grandi
attori le comunità ospitanti gli ospiti
che le misero e l'ambiente nel quale
l'interazione tra i primi due va in
scena solo quando i processi tra questi
tre protagonisti sono veramente i
bilanciati condivisi riequilibrati
possiamo parlare di una destinazione
fiorente e sostenibile proprio da questo
assunto
l'interpretazione della destinazione
turistica come un eco sistema vivente è
partito dolomiti paganella feature lab
un laboratorio immaginato e gestito
coinvolgendo l'intera comunità
dell'altopiano della paganella in
trentino per interpretare lo sviluppo
turistico come forza positiva e
costruire una comunità tenace coesa e
resiliente capace di affrontare in
maniera più consapevole ed equilibrata i
rischi e le opportunità che il futuro
riserva
[Musica]
nell'ottobre 2019 quando la pandemia era
ancora totalmente sconosciuta abbiamo
lanciato davanti ai nostri concittadini
la grande sfida di immaginare un futuro
diverso per la nostra destinazione
turistica
tutti gli indicatori classici in quella
data mostravano un territorio in grande
crescita dinamico veloce innovativo una
comunità pure dell'altopiano della
paganella fatta di 5.000 residenti
immersa tra le dolomiti di brenta
patrimonio unesco il parco naturale
adamello brenta il lago di molveno e nel
massiccio della paganella una comunità
capace di accogliere due milioni di
presenze turistiche hanno una comunità
in cui il turismo rappresenta il motore
di sviluppo e di sostentamento
principale quindi perché interrogarsi
sul futuro perché immaginare uno
scenario diverso e soprattutto perché
non lasciare tutto così com'è
d'altronde questa sarebbe stata la
scelta più semplice più li reale da
qualche tempo tuttavia emergevano
segnali importanti segnali di una nuova
sensibilità un nuovo modo di osservare i
flussi turistici ed i suoi impatti sulla
comunità una sensibilità percepita dal
gruppo di lavoro internazionale guidato
dall'azienda per il turismo dolomiti
paganella che ha costruito con il
feature lab una piattaforma per
disegnare insieme alla nostra comunità
il proprio futuro ma per ingaggiare
tutti i residenti e gli stakeholder
principali non bastano le sensibilità di
pochi lo sappiamo
abbiamo bisogno di qualche certezza in
più e la convinzione di essere sulla
strada giusta è arrivata proprio grazie
alla straordinaria partecipazione di
quegli 800 persone adulti ragazzi
anziani persino studenti che hanno
vissuto in maniera corale profonda la
serata lancio del dolomiti paganella
feature lab
ma le sorprese non si sono esaurite in
quella sera
il giorno successivo alla serata ho
personalmente ricevuto un emozionato
messaggio da parte una docente presente
con una delle classi medie
all'evento lancio la docente nel suo
messaggio riportato di essere entrata in
classe e di aver trovato gli studenti in
piedi ad applaudirla sorpresa ha chiesto
cosa c'è ragazzi perché è stato
applaudendo la risposta è stata grazie
prof per averci fatto vivere una serata
così straordinaria solo poche volte si
ha la fortuna di vivere momenti intensi
di assistere alla creazione di alchimie
uniche di respirare un'atmosfera
connettiva tra persone di età store e
ruoli diversi
questa e le altre storie ci riempie di
responsabilità e sono state proprio la
spinta più forte ad iniziare tutto il
processo di ricerca ed analisi nel 2019
con lo scoppio della pandemia la cover
19 il primo du role of dawn una prima
stagione estiva di compensazione di
transizione e poi il totale fermo della
stagione invernale ci siamo interrogati
spesso se continuare se la comunità
fosse ancora interessato
[Musica]
lo scenario in epoca kobe era infatti
totalmente cambiato rispetto a quello di
partenza da una fase di forte espansione
di benessere ad uno dei peggiori momenti
che questa comunità così come tante
altre avesse mai vissuto quindi come
mantenere alto l'interesse sul futuro
quando è presente così ingombrante così
forte
solo la consapevolezza di aver
anticipato temi fondamentali rese ancora
più reale e comprensibili dalla pandemia
ha dato la spinta ad andare avanti
modificando alcuni aspetti progettuali
ma non lo spirito di fondo del progetto
partendo dai perché profondi e dal tanto
con approccio il più possibile olistico
alla base del fenomeno turistico abbiamo
posto i quattro grandi interrogativi le
vere e proprie fondamenta su cui poggia
la costruzione del progetto dna di
destinazione
qual è il dna della destinazione cosa ci
rende veramente unici speciali come
territorio comunità e quindi
destinazione turistica
cosa possiamo imparare dal passato e
soprattutto perché qualcuno dovrebbe
pianificare la sua prossima vacanza sul
nostro territorio e non una valle vicino
numero due nuove generazioni come
possono le nuove generazioni in un
tessuto economico in maggioranza
gestione familiare disegnare la
destinazione che verrà siamo veramente
così sicuri che le nuove generazioni
vogliono in maniera che invita a seguire
i passi dei propri genitori
cosa potrebbe accadere se questo non
succedesse numero tre cambiamenti
climatici come potrà la nostra
destinazione per sperare in un futuro in
cui cambiamenti climatici sono ormai una
certezza la chiamano anche crisi
climatica possiamo aspettare che le cose
vadano avanti da sole subendo questi
cambiamenti
oppure essere fragili
gere e ridisegnando non solo la nostra
stagione invernale ma anche le altre tre
stagioni dell'anno numero 4 turismo in
equilibrio cosa vuol dire davvero
sviluppare il turismo in modo più
sostenibile ed equilibrato come possiamo
pensare di ridurre il traffico
indirizzare i nostri turisti di luoghi
anche meno conosciuti del territorio
ispirare gli stessi a visitare la nostra
destinazione anche al di fuori delle
classiche stagioni e dei picchi
stagionali e al tempo stesso mantenere
le nostre naturali e risorse naturali in
equilibrio questa è una domanda
importantissima che la domanda che mette
in relazioni tutte le altre quattro
dimensioni saetta previsa vien più lenta
recitava dante alighieri 700 anni fa nel
canto 17 del paradiso ed è proprio con
questo spirito quello di anticipare il
futuro non subirlo essere gli artefici
in maniera collettiva
questi sono stati gli spunti che hanno
ci hanno fatto costruire i quattro
grandi interrogativi sui quattro camente
relative abbiamo appoggiato tutte le
scelte metodologiche che hanno visto la
realizzazione di più di 15 workshop con
più di 200 persone che hanno partecipato
due indagini su turisti sia in estate
che in inverno per capire anche la loro
disponibilità a cambiare i comportamenti
e modelli di fruizione turistica
classica e poi soprattutto una grande
indagine svolta su tutti gli abitanti
del territorio
in questo caso quello dell'indagine le
domande hanno cercato di mettere in luce
sia i fattori positivi che i flussi
turistici portano alla comunità ma forse
per la prima volta anche gli aspetti più
complessi gli impianti più nascosti che
gli stessi flussi turistici possono
generare ragionare sul concetto di
qualità della vita della comunità e non
solo su quello della qualità
dell'esperienza turistica
questo è stato l'obiettivo principale
dell'indagine svolta su tutti residenti
dell'altopiano della paganella ma le
domande si sa bisogna provare a dare
anche delle risposte
le risposte che hanno bisogno anche di
un nuovo vocabolario popolato non gli
obiettivi non solo gli obiettivi
quantitativi dati e performance ma
soprattutto di valori
per questo stiamo creando la carta dei
valori
ispirandoci alle antiche ma modernissime
carte di regola gli strumenti normativi
attraverso i quali le comunità trentine
dal medioevo all'inizio dell'ottocento
regolarono da se lo sfruttamento delle
risorse naturali e organizzarono la loro
vita civile
per questo consegneremo alla comunità 10
dichiarazioni in grado di guidare uno
sviluppo equilibrato per i prossimi 20
anni
la carta dei valori manca un ultimo
fondamentale passaggio dei valori alle
idee idee che si concretizzano i
progetti reali capaci di tracciare
l'agenda della vita dell'evoluzione
della destinazione da grandi progetti
visionari in grado di modificare anche
gli aspetti infrastrutturali a scelte
consapevoli verso nuovi modelli di
sviluppo fino a semplici comportamenti
quotidiani da adottare e trasferire come
buone pratiche anche agli ospiti che
scelgono il nostro territorio come
spazio per la propria esperienza di
vacanza
questo è il catalogo progetti e il
catalogo progetti sarà insieme alla
carta dei valori il lascito principale
del dolomiti paganella fece un lato un
lascito che altro non è che un nuovo
inizio un inizio che rappresenta il
ciclo di vita della destinazione intesa
come un eco sistema vivente capace di
evolvere curarsi e rigenerarsi